alors bienvenue dans la ville de vola euh je vais parler
brièvement du cockpit le pilote est assis
sur le côté gauche le passager a été
touché sur la droite c'est contrôlé par
un manche central et ils on a un
tableau de bord simple euh devant nous
[Musique]
formation mais comme je l'ai dit plus tôt, ils sont
très simples à piloter
[Musique]
[Rires]
oh
ce qui va se passer, c'est que nous prendrons
des pilotes d'hélicoptère expérimentés et aussi
des pilotes d'avions fixes et nous leur apprendrons
les différences pour piloter cet avion  mais
la bonne nouvelle est qu'il est très simple à piloter,
il dispose d'un système de commande de vol numérique très intelligent,
donc l'ironie est que pour
les pilotes d'hélicoptère, ils devront
désapprendre de nombreuses compétences très intelligentes et
réapprendre à piloter un avion simplement
parce que c'est beaucoup plus simple à piloter que
dis un hélicoptère
étranger
[Musique]
[Rires] [
Musique] [
Rires] [
Musique]
[Musique]
c'est la redondance donc quand on regarde
aussi nos véhicules où je me tiens
ici en ce moment la redondance la plus évidente
sont nos Moteurs
vf18 donc  si un moteur tombe en panne ou deux, cela
n'a pas d'importance, nous pouvons toujours voler en toute sécurité
sur un hélicoptère vous avez un moteur un
rotor si vous avez un problème mécanique
vous avez un problème
cette redondance complète que nous avons dans notre
système global ainsi que ce soit sur le vol
contrôler la batterie donc toujours quand un
système ne fonctionne pas, l'autre rattrape
l'étranger
[Musique]